it it's a mass shooting scene there are
uh four people deceased inside the house
and then there was one eight-year-old
that was life-flighted to area hospital
and that eight-year-old has also passed
he has ma'am yes so a total of five
people have died here that is correct
all right and you also told me that
three children were also injured well
there was three children covered in
blood and when we got here we loaded
them up on an ambulance with EMS and
sent them to an area hospital they
checked them and no injuries
my understanding is is that the the
victims they came over to the fence said
hey do you mind not shooting uh out in
the yard we have a young baby that
that's trying to go to sleep and he had
been drinking and he says I'll do what I
want to in my front yard
the the suspect has been known to shoot
his AR-15 style 223 out in the front
yard and that's evidenced by the amount
of casings that we found in the front in
his front yard we have identified who he
is due to a ring doorbell camera